I just read the most disturbing story
may be that I have ever read most
disturbing news story
I'm not going to read it I'm not going
to go too into detail at all because
this is just
horrifying it's by Mia cathell on Town
Hall I hope I'm not mispronouncing Mia's
last name
headline tapes we investigated a
Suburban LGBT pedophile ring here's what
we found
and it's a story of these two guys these
two gay guys who are in a gay marriage
and they adopted children two male
children they adopted the children from
a nominally Christian adoption agency
obviously a Christian adoption agency
that endorses
same-sex marriage adoption I it would be
hard for me to understand how that's a
Christian adoption agency but they do it
and then the guys just constantly raped
the children and just very young
children now that the the guys have been
caught the children are ages 9 and 11.
they bragged about raping the children
they made you know all sorts of videos
and things they invited their friends to
do it that's if you want to read the
grizzly details it's over a Town Hall
you can give it a read
not for the faint of heart so I don't
necessarily recommend you do it
obviously these men if they are guilty
of what what they are accused of doing
obviously they should be executed
there's no question about that as far as
I'm concerned even if you are a little
worried about the death penalty and even
if you have objections to the death
penalty which I do not I think the death
penalty is perfectly just and legitimate
and Christian and acceptable but even if
you do uh one
I I think irrefutable
argument for the death penalty Beyond
mere retribution
which I think is ultimately the point of
all criminal justice but but beyond that
you could you you would have to say that
for the purposes of protecting the
public from the further predations of
these animals these absolute criminals
uh the death penalty would be justified
at the very least to protect people if
not purely for the purpose of justice
and retribution at least to protect
people and you know with the way that
our justice system works now if these
pedos go to prison well if there were
Justice in the prison system they would
not last very long in prison but if they
did if they did make it you know they'd
be let out you know they'd be let out we
don't we don't keep criminals in jail in
this country not these days
they probably would be let out and what
would they do they'd do it again
so sure we I think most most reasonable
people agree these two men should be
executed very swiftly for what they did
but when will we address the broader
issues
are we going to address the broader
issue are we willing to end the Absurd
and barbaric practice of same-sex and
single parent adoption
and certainly when it comes to single
parent adoption certainly single male
parent adoption
I think single parent adoption generally
should be
discouraged if not just made illegal
outright certainly same-sex adoption
should be illegal a child has a right to
his natural mother and father to it to
to be conceived within the context of a
marriage and in the conjugal Act of his
parents
we know that there are something like 36
couples trying to adopt every newborn
baby put up production in the United
States there's no shortage of mommies
and daddies married to one another who
want to adopt babies okay there's no
shortage of that at all
and yet because of wokeness and
political correctness we've got to say
no well we shouldn't discriminate
against gay men or single parents who
want to adopt but of course we should
because it's not about the adults
whether they want to satisfy the most
horrific lusts they could have or
whether they just want a kid and they
didn't get married and they just want to
have a kid
we we know that it is better for a child
to be raised in a marriage in a real
marriage with a mother and a father and
so at the very least for newborn babies
where the situation is really really
straightforward
we should prioritize the children over
the parents no question about that we're
not allowed to say that that's not
politically correct we're not allowed to
point out that
child sex abuse is much more prevalent
among LGBT identified people I'm not
saying all gay guys are child abusers
obviously that is not the case the vast
majority of gay guys are not child
abusers
but the numbers are the numbers the LGBT
identification in the United States is
7.1 percent Accord that's according to
Gallup according to the Williams
Institute at UCLA law so not some
far-right Think Tank according to a very
liberal storied institution 20 of
registered sex offenders identify as
LGBT we're not allowed to say that we're
not allowed to confront that fact
because it's Politically Incorrect so
what happens these stories pop up and
you don't read about it anywhere you
read about it in town hall maybe you
hear it on my show and that's it and it
gets buried
for what so that we can continue
perpetuating lies that harm all of
society that harms certain people
specifically but harm all of us when we
are forced to live in a culture of Lies
We should say no to that
[Music]